amazing all right aluminarium has
launched its ultra lounge experience a
new trendy spot to dance and listen to
great music and here to tell us more
about it is general manager callum
pearson thank you for being here julie
thanks so much for having me we were
just talking a minute ago you guys are
always doing something new and exciting
over at illuminarium let's talk about
what this ultra lounge is and what
people can expect when they come in
absolutely so ultra lounge is the friday
and saturday night life identity for a
luminarium down at area 15. it's a
state-of-the-art technology venue where
we get to enjoy nightlife the way it was
originally intended remember those times
when we all collected on the dance floor
and it was all about
getting together and unifying over a
genre of music that we all loved that's
what we wanted to bring it back to get
out of the commercial and back into that
vibe of people dancing and we're seeing
some video here it looks like so much
fun i've been seeing it on social media
and in addition to the music i mean just
the whole experience around you you guys
kind of factor that in obviously as well
for the lounge we did i mean we still
have the vip booths we still do bottle
service but we wanted the area of the
floor to really be its own uh entity and
for something that you could connect
with so we have 42 50k projectors that
are giving you 360 degree immersive
projection while you're on the floor and
the floor itself is also projected upon
so it's it's an environment where just
be yourself come down as yourself we're
not going to ask a dress code of you we
want you to have fun we want you to have
connections with other people that are
out there on the floor well it sounds
like so much fun and i've been in there
before so i know just seeing it all
around you is unlike anything else and
you guys really highlight our local djs
too right we do our friday nights is
called locals love and uh we've been
able to get such a collective stable of
local djs that we want to highlight
we're so proud to be part of the las
vegas community and we've just uh run
it's not really a competition but a
search for other local djs they've been
submitting we're about to go through
those submissions to find out who's
going to be playing next and that's
that's a huge part of what we want to do
well and you guys think of it all and uh
you told me we have something new coming
up tell us really quickly what's going
on so we've got two quick new things
that i want to talk about first of all
is that we have this line of infused
alcohol for the night time where uh
we've been soaking things over jalapenos
for a long time to get a real spicy
margarita so that's a little special and
also we're about to break into sports
programs in the luminarian where you'll
get to sit on the field and watch your
favorite games as part of a collective
as well so that's coming soon you're
about to see a press release wow that is
so much fun i can't wait to see you guys
think of everything thank you so much
for being here be sure to go check out
everything they have going on at
illuminarium and las vegas now we'll be
right back